[Música]
miles de personas marchan en eeuu en
contra de iniciativas que buscan
restringir el acceso al aborto las
movilizaciones se producen dos días
antes de que la corte suprema de mayoría
conservadora discuta una causa con la
que se podrían prohibir la mayoría de
los abortos luego de 15 semanas de
embarazo
en brásil miles de ciudadanos inundaron
las calles de río de janeiro para pedir
la destitución del presidente ya ir
bolsonaro cuando falta exactamente un
año para las elecciones presidenciales
los manifestantes criticaron el manejo
de la pandemia y culparon al mandatario
por la subida de los precios tenemos
recortes
ya son más de 1000 las construcciones
afectadas por la lava del volcán cumbre
vieja que continúa en erupción entre el
viernes y el sábado se han registrado al
menos 21 terremotos en torno en el
entorno del volcán mientras la calidad
del aire mejora ampliamos desde la isla
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torres sánchez iniciamos
en eeuu miles de mujeres marchan en
diferentes ciudades del país contra los
recientes intentos para restringir el
acceso al aborto incluida una reciente
ley en textos que prohíbe las
interrupciones después de las 6 semanas
las 660 movilizaciones convocadas se
producen días antes de que la corte
suprema de mayoría conservadora discuta
una causa de misisipí que podría
invalidar el histórico caso round road
versus white de 1973 con lo que algunos
estados se verían facultados para
implementar políticas más restrictivas
respecto a la interrupción del embarazo
es de suma importancia que nos
aseguremos de que roe versus wait se
mantenga si eso no sucede necesitaremos
protección bajo la ley federal para que
mujeres y doctores en el estado de
michigan y en todo eeuu no sean
encarcelados literalmente y convertidos
en reos por ejercer su derecho a elegir
continuamos en eeuu luego de que la
votación sobre el proyecto de ley de
infraestructuras se suspendiera a raíz
de las divisiones en el interior del
partido demócrata el presidente joe
biden dijo que trabajará con fuerza para
lograr la aprobación del que es
considerado uno de los puntos más
importantes de su agenda
espero que los republicanos no sean
irresponsables de rechazar el aumento
del techo de la deuda
eso sería inconcebible nunca se ha hecho
antes y espero que no pase soy realista
fui senador por mucho tiempo sé cómo se
legisla no hay ninguna razón por la que
estos dos proyectos no puedan aprobarse
de forma independiente excepto que no
haya votos para hacerlo de esa manera es
una propuesta sencilla
en otras noticias miles de ciudadanos
marcharon en las calles de la ciudad
brasileña de río de janeiro para pedir
un juicio político que lleve a la
destitución del presidente ya ir
bolsonaro desde allí nuestra periodista
fanny letter nos dio más detalles es la
primera vez que la oposición brasileña
se junta y sale
un mes después de las grandes
manifestaciones a favor de jair
bolsonaro el presidente brasileño que
había pronunciado un discurso
antidemocrático que preocupó la
comunidad internacional y las
instituciones brasileñas
los manifestantes bajan en las calles de
las principales ciudades del país como
aquí en el centro del río de janeiro y
piden todos la destitución inmediata del
presidente brasileño que acusan de haber
llevado el país a una crisis
y económica sin precedentes
[Música]
porque ha hecho un trabajo terrible en
el manejo de la pandemia con más de
medio millón de brasileños muertos es
negacionista es culpable por la falta de
trabajo el desempleo los precios altos
todo esto es el resultado de una persona
que no tiene la menor capacidad de ser
presidente y necesitamos deshacernos de
bolsonaro tener elecciones así que
hagamos lo
repudiamos lo que dijo bolsonaro en la
onu repudiamos todas las mentiras que
dijo allí la realidad es que brasil está
pasando hambre está desempleado y
necesita una nueva política
[Música]
las disculpas picadas
ahora no es el momento de disputas
insignificantes es el momento de
mantenerse firmes unidos y pensar en
brasil es hora de deshacerse
evolucionado somos la mayoría de la
gente en las calles las calles son
nuestras
muchos de los manifestantes presentes
hoy ponen dos de sus esperanzas en la
posible candidatura del ex presidente
luiz inácio lula da silva para poder ser
perdonado en las próximas elecciones
presidenciales pero lula no va a todos
los fondos una gran parte de la
oposición está organizada en uno de los
numerosos escándalos de corrupción que
han vengan la clase política brasileña a
casi una lluvia donde las próximas
elecciones presidenciales la oposición
brasileña sigue dividida vamos ahora
españa continúa el flujo de lava en la
isla de la palma debido a la apertura de
nuevas bocas en el volcán cumbre vieja
se estima que ya se han expulsado unos
80 millones de metros cúbicos de lava
desde que entró en erupción hace casi
dos semanas y sólo en los últimos dos
días se han producido 20 terremotos en
la región en varias zonas las
autoridades levantaron la medida que
instaba a la población a quedarse en
casa debido a la mala calidad del aire
que tuvo una mejoría en las últimas
horas sin embargo hay otros lugares
donde permanece la recomendación de no
salir a exteriores conectamos con
nuestra enviada especial a la isla del
aura cambote laura cuáles son los
detalles más recientes al respecto
bueno pues lo que se puede decir es que
hay unas mejoras aquí en la isla de la
palma las últimas coladas de lava que se
habían formado ayer pues se han juntado
han fusionado con la colada y la primera
colada de lava principal esta colada de
lava esto significa que no va a dañar
unas zonas que estaban particularmente
amenazadas otra buena noticia lo ha
dicho se ha levantado el confinamiento
para unas personas que estaban
confinadas alrededor de mí donde me
encuentro en unos pueblos se ha
levantado el confinamiento lo han
decidido las autoridades porque según
los científicos la calidad del aire es
mejor es menos peligrosa para el ser
humano hay menos dióxido de azufre en el
aire ahora pero aún así la situación
sigue muy tensas muy intensas y muy
complicada porque el volcán sigue en una
fase explosiva como lo puede ver detrás
de mí los daños materiales
tienen enormes 400 millones de euros de
daños materiales lo recordamos lo ha
dicho hay más de 1000 edificios que
están dañados por la lava bueno sabemos
que ya son más de 1000 inmuebles
destruidos pero además de las personas
que han perdido sus hogares una de las
situaciones más complicadas es la que
viven los agricultores
sí especialmente los agricultores que se
ocupan de plataneras porque este sábado
ha roto una tubería por causa de la
colada una tubería que suministraba agua
de riego para unas 600 hectáreas de
plataneras el consejo de la palma dice
que va a empezar las obras para arreglar
esto este lunes pero podría [__] en
mucho tiempo muestra la situación
detención en la cual están ahora los
agricultores aquí porque la agricultura
las frutas y la verdura son la primera
riqueza en la isla representan el 50 por
ciento de sus ingresos ayer estuvimos
hablando con varios agricultores y nos
han dicho que han tenido que despedir a
mucha gente más de decenas de personas
porque ya no hay trabajo para ellas
porque las hectáreas están completamente
destruidas laura pues muchas gracias por
todos estos detalles estamos muy
pendientes de lo que pueda ocurrir en
las próximas horas ahora finalizó en la
cumbre previa finalizó la reunión previa
a la cumbre climática con 26 que se
celebraba en milán en ella los delegados
de los países acordaron la necesidad de
reunir anualmente 100 mil millones
dólares para ayudar a las naciones más
vulnerables frente a la emergencia
climática y actuar con más vehemencia
para mantener el calentamiento global
por debajo de 15 grados alva santana
tiene los detalles
fin de la reunión precop 26 en italia a
un mes de la cumbre climática de glasgow
las delegaciones llegaron a la
conclusión de que hay que hacer más para
combatir la crisis climática
keating hubo consenso en que necesitamos
hacer más colectivamente en términos de
nuestros compromisos en términos de
contribuciones y varias partes señalaron
que obviamente depende de todos nosotros
pero particularmente de las naciones del
g20 que representan el 80 por ciento de
las emisiones
james jones en esta línea los 50
representantes ambientales acordaron
mayores esfuerzos para mantener el
calentamiento global por debajo de los
15 grados centígrados y coincidieron en
la necesidad de lanzar un paquete de 100
mil millones de dólares anualmente para
ayudar a las naciones más vulnerables
frente al cambio climático de
materializarse esta ayuda no llegaría
hasta después de 2025 a pesar del mal
pronóstico ambiental algunos delegados
se mostraron optimistas
la conclusión es amigos que tal y como
estamos hoy aquí podemos hacer grandes
progresos en glasgow avanzando
rápidamente hacia los nuevos objetivos
que la ciencia nos dice que debemos
alcanzar charangas gamers teacher el
preludio de la cob 26 coincidió con las
manifestaciones de jóvenes
ambientalistas reunidos en la cumbre de
eufor climate exigen a los gobiernos
mundiales más acciones para frenar la
crisis climática
y desde hace varios días reino unido
enfrenta una crisis que ha dejado sin
combustible a millones de personas por
lo que intervendrá personal del ejército
a partir del lunes para ayudar a
transportar el carburante los efectos
del break sheet han provocado que miles
de conductores extranjeros dejarán de
trabajar allí y en consecuencia varios
sectores de la economía están afectados
la hotelería y la industria porcina
también son víctimas de la crisis del
informe desde andre amaya
una crisis que tardará en ser superada
la falta de combustible en reinounido
atribuida a los efectos del break city y
la pandemia de kobe 19 obligó al
gobierno a llamar a 200 militares para
que ayuden a transportar el carburante a
diferentes estaciones de servicio
creo que es muy importante que podamos
llamar a los militares en un momento
como éste para ese apoyo extra que
brinde confianza y tenerlo como una
medida posible como una precaución
porque como digo la situación se está
estabilizando nadie va a fingir que ha
vuelto completamente a la normalidad
desearía que así fuera
pero creo que tener al ejército
disponible es algo muy sensato en lo que
hay que pensar
londres insiste en que la situación está
mejorando
sin embargo gremios independientes y
conductores aseguran que podría empeorar
en los próximos días
lo cubren que vaya guau el problema en
reino unido es que nadie más tiene estos
problemas a causa del break si las
fronteras los puestos de control la
salud la seguridad es una pérdida de
tiempo en las fronteras
escenas caóticas en varias estaciones de
servicios se vieron esta semana en
londres donde hubo largas filas de gente
esperando llenar los tanques de sus
vehículos el break city la pandemia se
combinaron este año para dejar también
una profunda escasez de mano de obra en
la economía británica se ha anunciado
que miles de cerdos tendrán que ser
sacrificados ya que no hay personal que
procese la carne también hay una falta
de trabajadores en el sector de la
hostelería y muchas tiendas de menos
recibir suficientes suministros antes de
navidad' miles de visas han sido
emitidas para mano de obra extranjera
pero hasta ahora parece no ser
suficiente
el presidente de filipinas rodrigo
duterte anunció este sábado que dejará
la política al final de su mandato hacia
abandona sus planes para presentarse a
vicepresidente en las elecciones de 2022
su retiro alimenta los rumores de que su
hija podría lanzarse para sucederlo
el hombre fuerte de filipinas renunciará
a seguir en el poder el presidente
rodrigo de uther te aseguro que no se
postulará al cargo de vicepresidente en
las próximas elecciones de mayo de 2022
y anuncio mi retiro de la política
duterte ha construido la mayor parte de
su gestión basada en la lucha contra las
drogas el 20 de septiembre de 2016
amenazó con liderar una campaña
sanguinaria contra los traficantes pero
también contra los consumidores no hay 3
millones de drogadictos en filipinas me
encantaría matarlos a todos
en mis gatos lo terminan
una política brutal que provocó miles de
muertos en el país cientos de
testimonios denuncian ejecuciones fuera
del marco de la ley de narcotraficantes
en todo el territorio
cuáles son tus pecados yo que les dije
los militares por ejemplo larroudé algún
peso de piso
perseguía a alguien a quien me
encarcelen de napo longo mis únicos
pecados son las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales en
la corte penal internacional por su
parte autorizó la apertura de una
investigación el 15 de septiembre de
2021 por sospecha de crímenes de lesa
humanidad rodrigo duterte ya no es tan
popular como cuando asumió el cargo
aceptación de la que sí goza su hija
sara posible candidata a sucederlo en
los comicios de mayo donde se espera que
voten unos 60 millones de electores
cientos de globos aerostáticos llenaron
de color el cielo de la ciudad de
albuquerque en el estado estadounidense
de nuevo méxico el festival
internacional de globos volvió a
celebrarse tras un año suspendido según
datos oficiales 588 globos hicieron
parte de la fiesta que reunió a miles de
espectadores
con estas imágenes llegamos al final del
informativo los invitamos a continuar
con nosotros en france24 punto com
[Música]